yeah I kind of messed up on this one
I'll be honest there is a story behind
how this happened though and it starts
with my dad
so my dad is one of my personal heroes
and one of the great many reasons for
that is because the decades he raised
money for charity
by running the bath bath math but pretty
much every year at my childhood that I
can remember he would run the bath bath
to raise money for Dorothy house which
is a Cancer Hospice in Barre which
provides end-of-life care and counseling
to patients and that included both of my
dad's parents my grandparents however my
dad has now been banned from running by
his doctor and more importantly my mum
because his joints are just a little bit
knackered from all those years of
running raising money for charity my
joints however my knees are absolutely
fine
well my joints are in tip-top condition
though because I'm 40 years younger than
him and apparently in the prime of my
life so I wanted to continue his
tradition of raising money for charity
by running now this is something that I
actually have already tried to do in
2017 where pig's ago my girlfriend and I
both signed up to run the Cambridge half
marathon and we were trained several
months beforehand I got to the point
where I could run six miles and then
only picks will go finished the actual
race basically what I'd done is what I
always do but you're spectacularly
overdo it I went too fast see far too
soon and sponsor short range at my knee
quite badly pencil got a swore that she
was never gonna do it ever again and so
when the registration period came along
again last year she immediately signed
up and implored me to do the same I was
dedicated I was gonna do it and then I
just kind of didn't get round to it I
did however want to train with her and
go on exactly the same training regime
but take it a little bit more slowly and
not push so hard this time
I find out to do another ace I sign up
to do the well in a half an hour also
not long after the Cambridge huh so I
could train with her and I'd be a good
fitness to do that one except by some
miracle
some people drops out the Cambridge half
and there are a handful of places
available and I saw this I got the email
and within 30 seconds I was on the
website and I without thinking just got
myself a place in the Cambridge half
I was super lucky to do that I called
her I was super excited I was like we
can run the race together at last it was
what we plan to do all along and then I
remembered there was a problem because I
was already running a half marathon in
March and if my 2° serves me right
two half marathons together make a full
marathon so I'm now going from running
no more than six miles at a time in my
life to doing a marathon split in two so
this is gonna hurt this is going to be
extremely painful and we are halfway
through our training regime already it
is going well but I can tell this is
gonna hurt a lot so if you'd like to
support me in this official act of
torture I am raising money for two
charities
half the money I raise is going to be
going to Dorothea house the counts as
hospice that my dad raised money for in
bath and the other half is going to be
going to a charity that I'm introducing
to the mix which is personal to me which
is Durrell Wildlife Conservation Trust
their charity I've worked with on this
channel several times in the past
there are charity who stopped species
from going extinct they're dedicated to
preserving biodiversity on this planet
for our future generations I think it
some of the most important work that any
charity is doing in the world that is
why I am supporting them so there is a
link to a Just Giving page down there in
the doobly-doo if you can spare any
money whatsoever if you have a charity
budget or if you're just feeling
generous please do go to that link and
give whatever you can the closing date
for that page is the date of the second
half marathon I'm doing which is I can't
remember but I'll put it on the screen
I'm more worried about the first one I
have to do if I'm honest but once I've
done both parts of the marathon then
that page is gonna be shut down and I'm
gonna be taking half the money giving it
to Darkly house I'm gonna be taking the
other half and giving it to to Durrell
I'm aiming for five hundred pounds in
total but if we could go beyond that if
we
smashed through a thousand pounds that
would be incredible take what to make
life more interesting
if they're just giving gets to a
thousand pounds bigger Oh run the half
my friends in a costume and the person
who donates the most are the biggest
individual donation or a groups out
donation
I'll dress up as what'd you say I said
so person in Center for you please be
kind these charities mean a great deal
to me both through my family and through
my academic work and my beliefs of what
we should be doing for the planet so if
you could support and even in the
slightest way it would be incredibly
appreciated there's a link to the Just
Giving page down in the description and
if you got a few quid spare then I the
two charities was very much appreciated
so please go and do that now he excuse
me I need to be robbed eat everywhere on
my body